EÉmilie Nicolas, Stéphanie
GrGrammond et Christian Dufour.
EÉmilie va arriver dans quelques
sesecondes. Mais vous êtes pas
spspécialiste des vaccins. Maisn
pepeut se poser la question : e-
cece que ça va pas faire dérailr
lele plan de vaccination, parce
ququ'il y a quand même beaucoupe
dodoses qu'on ne pourra pas
ututiliser et deux, surtout peu-
êêtre envoyer une crainte
adadditionnelle chez la populatn
faface à la vaccination? Je vous
fafais entendre Docteur Arruda t
onon vous revient.
DrDr HORACIO ARRUDA, directeur
nanational de santé publique, Qc
- - Si on nous enlève 300 000
dodoses, bien c'est 300 000
pepersonnes de moins qu'on peut
vavacciner avec ce vaccin-là.
DoDonc, ça a un impact sur
lala logistique. Ça retarde
unun peu certaines clientèles
ququ'on voulait vacciner un peu
plplus tôt. C'est une autre tuie
dadans... dans le programme.
MaMais on va tout faire...
EtEt pour nous, c'est important
ququand même que la vaccination
ququ'on fait au Québec soit
sésécuritaire. Il faut vacciner,
mamais pas vacciner à tout prix.
- - C'est le principe. Stéphani,
jeje commence avec vous.
EÉditorialiste à la presse. Je
susuis très heureux de vous voià
cece panel. C'est le principe de
prprudence qui a guidé les
prprovinc?
- - Oui, c'est une excellente
chchose, mais c'est vrai qu'on
pepeut se poser la question, pae
quque c'est le deuxième changemt
d'd'orientation à propos de ce
vavaccin en peu de temps. On avt
didit au départ : pour les
pepersonnes de 65 ans et plus, e
nonom, ensuite c'est oui,
mamaintenant, pour les 55 ans et
momoins, ce n'est plus recomman.
C'C'est certain que dans la
popopulation, ça peut jeter un
dodoute. Il y a des risques des
ététudes en Europ qui ont démoné
ququ'il peut y avoir des
ththromboses très graves au
cecerveau qui résulte de ce
vavaccin. Des cas rares, mais
ququand même grave. En même tem,
ilil faut mettre tout ça dans la
babalance et penser que le vacc,
évévidemment, il a un effet qui
esest bénéfique et la COVID
pepermet... la COVID va faire en
sosorte qu'on a des thromboses e
fafaçon beaucoup plus fréquente.
EsEst-ce que c'est plus avantagx
dede prendre le vaccin?
PrProbablement que oui, mais ily
a a une précaution à prendre. Le
vavaccin n'a pas besoin d'être
cocongelé. Ça permettait de
l'l'acheminer à des clientèles
pepeut-être plus vulnérables à a
mamaison. Il faut mettre tout ça
dadans la balance et voir au bot
dudu compte.
- - Ça tombe mal, parce que les
gegens vont dire : AstraZeneca,
nonon merci. Il y aura beaucoupe
pépédagogie à faire. Les médias,
leles scientifiques.
- - Absolument. On le voyait déà
auau niveau de la vaccination ds
leles cliniques quand les premis
dodoutes avaient été lancés au
niniveau d'AstraZeneca. Les gens
avavaient beaucoup de questions.
L'L'approche du gouvernement n't
papas de vacciner de force
pepersonne, donc si les citoyens
onont des questions, il faut
prprendre le temps d'y répondre.
PoPour l'instant, on voit que la
coconsigne vient encore de
chchanger. Si elle change à
nonouveau, plus que la consigne
chchange souvent, plus que ça
prprend de la pédagogie que les
gegens sont mêlés. Il va falloir
lele comprendre. C'est ce que
AsAstraZeneca, c'est un gros
momorceau du portfolio de
vavaccination du Canada. Donc ça
pepeut aussi faire en sorte quee
ququ'on nous avait promis au
niniveau de la campagne de
vavaccination qui se termine por
lala Saint-Jean le 24 juin, il
pepeut y avoir des délais à ce
niniveau si on ne peut pas compr
susur sa vaccin pour une grande
papartie de la population adulte
auau Canada.
- - Christian Dufour, c'est
emembêtant quand même?
- - C'est comme s'il y avait une
mamalédiction qui pesait sur sa
vavaccin. Ça discrédite l'enseme
dedes vaccin. Mettez-vous à la
plplace des gens qui ont 56 ansà
ququi on va offrir le vaccin qui
n'n'est pas recommandé aux gensn
babas de 55 ans. Ce que je troue
trtrès triste, c'est l'état de
nonotre société qui n'est plus
cacapable de supporter aucun
ririsque. On aurait pu penser à
autrefois, que les avantages
ememportaient tellement sur les
ririsques qu'on procéderait. Mas
onon est plus là-dedans. On est
dadans le principe de précaution
sysystématique, dans le risque
zézéro. Ça cause des gros
dodommages. J'en parlais à
MoMonsieur Arruda tantôt. Au-deà
dede la perte de crédibilité qui
esest quand même le moyen de nos
sosortir de ce grand malheur, la
vavaccination, il y a des
cecentaines de milliers de doses
ququ'on ne peut pas utiliser
mamaintenant. Je me désole. Je
trtrahis mon âge, qu'on soit reu
àà ce point, dès qu'il y a un
prproblème, on voit juste le
prproblème et on est plus capabe
dede voir les avantages.
- - Ce sont des programmes grav,
mamais sur un petit nombre.
- - Mais sans que le avantage
ememportait très nettement sur s
prproblèmes. Il y a toujours des
prproblèmes dans la vie.
- - Je vais faire un tour de tae
rarapide, mais avant, je vais vs
fafaire entendre Monsieur Dubé r
l'l'adhésion. Parce qu'il y a ds
gegens qui demandent au
gogouvernement du Québec de
rerefermer. On aurait voulu chez
cecertains qu'on annule le retor
enen classe à temps plein pour s
élélèves du secondaire et du
cécégep. Or, Monsieur Dubé répod
cececi :
CHCHRISTIAN DUBÉ, ministre, Sané
etet Services sociaux, Québec
- - On s'attendait qu'avec
dedes mesures de déconfinement i
sosont là pour la santé mentale,
pupuis ça, on le sait, c'est
imimportant pour les écoles,
c'c'est important pour l'ensembe
dede la population, on le savait
ququ'il allait y avoir
unune augmentation des cas.
PuPuis ce qu'il faut respecter,
c'c'est l'adhésion aux mesures
popour que les gens continuent
d'd'adhérer aux mesures.
CeCe qui est notre plus grand di
enen ce moment, c'est que
dedes fois, il faut donner
unun petit quelque chose.
- - Christian, je commence avec
vovous. Ils disent : c'est bien
bebeau ce qui réclame toujours
plplus de mesure, mais si on fat
plplus de mesure et que personne
nene les respecte, ça ne sera
ririen.
- - Il y a la société qui est au
prprintemps. Ça fait un an que s
gegens font des efforts et ils
pepeuvent vivre. Je pense que tt
lele monde connaît les consignes
fofondamentales, mais le reste,a
dedevient très compliqué. Les gs
veveulent vivre. Il faut tenir
cocompte de ça, parce que c'est
bibien beau de mettre en oeuvre
d'd'autres conseils, mais si c't
papas appliqué... je suis venueà
pipied et je voyais dans les rus
etet dans les parcs des gens qui
nene respectent pas les consign.
PrProfiter de la vie.
- - Je comprends qu'on veut viv,
mamais en même temps, il y a une
esescalade des relâchements des
memesures sanitaires depuis la
sesemaine de relâche et on n'a s
nénécessairement eu le temps de
vovoir comment tout ça se cumul,
ququels sont les effets. On peut
sese demander : est-ce qu'elle
avavait départ, est-ce que c'étt
nénécessaire absolument de reler
papar exemple à 250 personnes ds
unun lieu de culte? Est-ce qu'on
avavait pu attendre encore un p?
LaLa question des écoles
sesecondaires, est-ce que c'état
nénécessaire de le faire tout de
susuite? C'est la balance. Oui l
y y a des problèmes de santé
mementale chez les jeunes, on le
vovoit. Il y a des problèmes de
viviolence conjugale, on l'a vu
avavec cette féminicide en cette
sesemaine. On a besoin d'avoir u
leleste, mais d'un autre côté, n
vovoit tous les variants qui s'n
viviennent. On sait que ça va êe
mamajoritaire dans le cas de COD
auau mois d'avril. On voit qu'iy
a a une troisième vague dans
plplusieurs pays d'Europe et aui
dadans des provinces comme la
CoColombie Britannique, l'Ontar.
- - Émilie?
- - Le problème, c'est le nombre
dede cas, mais surtout le nombre
d'd'hospitalisations et le nombe
dede personnes qui décèdent et e
nonombre des personnes aux soins
inintensifs. Le problème, c'est
ququ'on est trop tôt dans la
cacampagne de vaccination pour
ququ'il y ait encore plusieurs
pepersonnes à risque de
cocomplications qui ne sont pas
enencore vaccinées pendant que s
vavariants se promènent. Si on
ététait dans un monde où il y a
asassez de la population à risqe
ququi est vacciné, à ce moment,
l'l'arrivée d'une propagation ou
d'd'une hausse du nombre de cas
dedes personnes contaminées en
grgrande partie asymptomatique u
dedes symptômes pas graves, ça
seserait beaucoup moins grave.
L'L'important, c'est de ne pas
llâcher alors qu'on est à 1 km e
lala ligne d'a'arrivée. Il faut
s's'assurer que les personnes ls
plplus vulnérables sont vacciné.
OnOn n'a pas le risque d'avoir
cecette pression sur les hôpitax
sisi le nombre de cas augmente à
cece moment-là.
- - C'est logique, mais il y a
l'l'adhésion du monde réel qui t
llà-dedans. Il y a un élément
ququ'il faut souligner. Je sais
quque ça peut être la catastrope
dadans quelques semaines. Au
QuQuébec, il va y avoir moins de
momort, parce que l'hécatombe ds
momorts était dans les CHSLD. Cs
clclientèles sont vaccinées. Ila
y y avoir moins de mort.
- - Et il n'y a eu aucun cas das
l'l'art est ailleurs. Denis
CoCoderre, son livret retrouvé
MoMontréal. Je l'ai lu. Il y a
bebeaucoup de choses là-dedans.
EÉmilie, a-t-il réussi son entre
enen scène, d'abord? Qu'est-ce e
çaça vous inspire comme combat à
vevenir entre M. Coderre et Mme
PlPlante? Swisscom entrée en
scscène, ça veut dire faire parr
dede lui, de 57 sur avec la
ststratégie avec le livret. Ça
fafait des semaines qu'on en
paparle. Le fait que ça a été ts
lolong avant de déclarer
ofofficiellement sa candidature.
CÇa fait mousser le suspens. On
n'n'en parle beaucoup et c'est n
enen parle, c'est qu'il y a un
inintérêt. Au niveau du contenu,
jeje pense que c'est encore très
flflou pour beaucoup de personns
sisi la personne n'a vraiment
chchangé, mais aussi : c'est qui
sasa plateforme politique? Quand
onon parle de retrouvé Montréal,
jeje suis à Montréal depuis
ququelques années et je n'ai pas
l'l'impression que Montréal est
paparti nul part. Je ne sais pas
dede quoi on part techniquement,
coconcrètement. Ça va être
inintéressant pour projet Montrl
etet les autres candidats à la
mamairie de mettre leurs idées r
lala table. J'ai l'impression
ququ'on est dans une bataille
d'd'images en ce moment. Le
cocontraste au niveau politique
rereste à définir.
- - Effectivement, je pense que
c'c'est beaucoup dans le style.
LeLes gens se demandent : est-ce
quque Denis Coderre a changé? E-
cece que c'est vraiment un nouvl
hohomme ou c'est juste une caise
dede costumes, de lunettes, etc?
JeJe pense qu'on peut lui donner
ququand même le crédit des dire:
ilil a fait l'exercice, il a fat
unune introspection comédie. On
pepeut vouloir le croire. Par
cocontre, quand on regarde son
didiscours et la façon dont il
s's'est lancé, même les gens qui
sosont de son côté disent : on
ététait même pas au courant. Il
n'n'y a pas de travail dédié. On
l'l'accusait d'être un peu... de
memener un one man show. Et on
vovoit aussi qu'il est encore
atattaché par exemple au stade e
BeBelleval. Il dit : non, je vas
frfreiner mes ardeurs, mais il
enenchaîne en disant : finaleme,
sisi jamais ça peut se faire, on
vava y aller. Donc il modère ses
arardeurs, il est moins arrogan,
mamais on sent quand même que
c'c'est quand même la même
pepersonne qui est derrière la
crcravate.
- - Je pense que c'est la même
pepersonne et ce n'est pas juste
nénégatif. C'est une bonne
nonouvelle pour les montréalais
ququi vont avoir droit à une
cacampagne électorale très
didiversifiée sur le plan des
chchoix. Ce sont des personnes i
onont été mères et mairesses de
MoMontréal. Donc ils savent ce e
c'c'est. Je trouve qu'ils sont s
mamal déjà différenciés. Monsier
CoCoderre est pragmatique, c'est
papas un intellectuel. Il est ps
axaxé sur l'économie et il accue
leles gens, Mme Plante, d'être
ididéologue. Je trouve que cet
élélément, Monsieur Coderre est
plplus à droite, modéré. Mme
PlPlante à gauche. Il faut pas
ououblier une chose : Monsieur
CoCoderre a le handicap de son
papassé. On dit qu'il est
ararrogant. Ça me semble évident
ququ'il a changé. Comment ne
seserait-il pas changé?
CeCe qui est arrivé l'été dernir
ouoù beaucoup de montréalais ont
eueu l'impression à tort ou à
raraison que Mme Plante prenait
prprétexte du malheur collecti